the triplet loss is one good way to
learn the parameters of a confident for
face recognition there's another way to
learn these parameters let me show you
how face recognition can also be posed
as a straight binary classification
problem another way to train a neural
network is to take this pair of neural
networks to take this siamese network
and have them both compute these
embeddings maybe 128 dimensional
embeddings maybe even higher dimensional
and then have these beat input to a
logistic regression unit to then just
make a prediction where the target
output will be 1 if both of these are
the same persons and 0 if both of these
are of different persons so this is a
way to treat face recognition just as a
binary classification problem and this
is an alternative to the triplet loss
for training a system like this now what
is this final logistic regression unit
actually do the output Y hat will be
lets say a sigmoid function apply to
some set of features but rather than
just feeding in these encoding x' what
you can do is take the differences
between the encodings so let me show you
what I mean let's say I write a sum over
K equals 1 to 128 of let's say the
absolute value take an element-wise
between the two different encodings so
I'm just finished writing the sultan and
we'll see what this means so in this
notation f of X I is the encoding of the
image X I and the subscript K means to
just select out the kaif component of
this vector so this is taking the
element wise difference in absolute
values between these two and codings
and what you might do is think of these
128 numbers as features that you then
feed into logistic regression and your
final is regression
Canopus
parameters WI and be similar to a non
normal logistic regression unit and you
would train a appropriate waiting on
these 128 features in order to predict
whether or not these two images are of
the same person or of different persons
so this will be one pretty reasonable
way to learn to predict 0 or 1 whether
these are the same person
or different persons and there are few
other variations on how you can compute
this formula that I had underlined in
green for example another formula could
be this K minus f of X J ok squared
divided by f of X I plus f of X J okay
this is sometimes called the chi-square
formula right this is the Greek alphabet
Chi but this is are sometimes called the
chi-square similarity and this and other
variations are explored and this and
other variations are explored in this
deep face paper which I have referenced
earlier as well but so in this learning
formulation the input is a pair of
images so this is really your you know
training input X and the output Y is
either 0 or 1 depending on whether
you're inputting a pair of similar or
dissimilar images and same as before
you're training a siamese network so
that means that this neural network up
here as parameters that are the same or
they're really tied to the parameters in
this lower neural network and this
system can work pretty well as well um
lastly it doesn't mention one
computational trick that can help your
deployment significantly which is that
if this is the new image so this is an
employee walking in hoping that
turnstyle the doorway will open for them
and if this is from your data base image
then instead of having to compute this
set of features then instead of having
to compute this embedding every single
time what you can do is actually pre
compute that
so when the new employee walks in what
you can do is use this upper confidence
to compute that encoding and use it to
then compare it to your pre computed
encoding and then use that to make a
prediction y hat so because you don't
need to store the raw images and also
because if you have a very large
database of employees you don't need to
compute these encoding every single time
for every employee you know database
this idea of pre computing some of these
encoding can save a significant
computation and this type of
pre-computation works both for this type
of Sammys network architecture where you
feed face-recognition as a binary
classification problem as well as for
when you were learning and codings
may be using the triplet loss function
as described in the last couple of
videos and so just to wrap up to create
face verification as supervised learning
you create a training set of just pairs
of images now instead of triplets a
pairs of images where the target label
is one when these are a pair of pictures
of the same person and where the target
label is zero when these are pictures of
different persons and you use different
pairs to train the neural network to
train the siamese network using back
propagation so this version that you
just saw of treating face verification
and by extension face recognition as a
binary classification problem this works
quite well as well and so if that's I
hope that you now know what it would
take to train your own face verification
or your own face recognition system when
they can do one-shot learning